a liquid medication used to always come
in a bottle and you had to pour your
dose with a steady hand into a spoon
today many medications and supplements
come inside small food safe casings that
are easy to swallow and portable
Soft gel capsules many types of products
come in gel capsules from prescription
drugs to health supplements such as fish
oils many of these medicine Fields go
bad if exposed to oxygen so the gel cap
besides being convenient also serves as
a protective barrier
every ingredient in both the gel cap and
the medicine fill inside undergoes
extensive testing for purity
the first test phase checks for
bacterial contamination lab technicians
dissolve the ingredient in solution
apply it to a food source in a Petri
dish then incubate the dish for 72 hours
to encourage any existing bacteria to
grow then they draw samples and examine
them under a microscope if those samples
are bacteria free the ingredient moves
onto the second phase of testing which
checks for contaminants such as lead
arsenic Mercury and cadmium
this machine called a spectrometer
injects the ingredient solution into a
plasma flame then by reading the changes
in light wavelengths analyzes the
chemical composition if the ingredient
is contaminant free it gets the go-ahead
the gel cap is made entirely of natural
ingredients
gelatin derived from beef bones palm oil
glycerin and purified water the
proportions are top secret
an industrial blender combines the three
ingredients to a uniform consistency
that heats the mixture to 80 degrees
Celsius a vacuum sucks out the air
bubbles as this now ready gel material
flows into a holding tank
simultaneously they prepare the medicine
fill in this case vitamin D they combine
it with soybean oil to adjust the
potency to the specified strength
meanwhile they maintain the gel cap
material in the holding tank at 60
degrees Celsius to prevent it from
prematurely solidifying even the holes
leaving that tank is wrapped in heater
tape to keep the gel liquid
a separate hose feeds the vitamin D
solution from another holding tank down
to the production floor as well this
hose doesn't require heating because
vitamin D and soybean oil don't solidify
when cool
on the production line two stations
simultaneously spread a thin layer of
molten gel across a cooling drum
the gel hardens into a solid yet
malleable sheet about the thickness of
cardboard each sheet passes over a
rotating die with capsule-shaped
cavities
just before the two gel sheets come
together pumps inject the required
quantity of vitamin D solution into each
cavity the pressure pushing the gelatin
into the cavity
the same time the machine heats the gel
sheets so that when they meet they
adhere to each other forming full
capsules with the vitamin D solution
sealed inside in the final second the
dye's sharp edges slice the gel caps
free and they fall to a conveyor belt
below at this point the filled gel caps
contain a fair bit of moisture so
they're quite soft if they'd lay on a
Surface too long they'd flatten so the
conveyor belt whisks them very quickly
into a rotating drum where they tumble
in slightly cool dry air for about three
hours this removes enough moisture to
make the gel caps hard enough to lie on
a Surface without flattening
After exiting the gel caps move into a
second dryer wear spread out on trays
this time they dry for about 36 hours
after that the gel caps are hard enough
to be safely packaged
the gel caps the ones being packaged
here contain flax oil travel down a
series of vibrating plates which
progressively line them up in single
file
[Music]
as they pass by electronic eyes count
out the number of capsules per bottle
triggering The Filling mechanism to
collect that quantity and release it
into an empty bottle
[Music]
the next station applies a plastic twist
cap then the bottles move onward each
one plowing directly into the center of
an adhesive-backed label which rollers
then apply around the sides
before shipping the quality control lab
tests random samples from the production
batch to verify that the gel caps meet
all specifications
[Music]
it's a playground staple a stationary
ride-on cartoon animal that bounces up
and down and rocks back and forth
courtesy of a huge spring underneath
secured into the ground
the bouncy coil base is what gives this
type of playground equipment its name a
spring Rider the spring Rider is a
playground favorite to withstand years
of rambunctious Riders it has to be
solid and durable yet for a toddler to
be able to rock back and forth it can't
be too heavy that's why the spring is
made of thick steel and the animal of
lightweight aluminum
that sand core is comprised of two
halves each made with an aluminum mold
duck shaped in this case
workers fill it with sand and adhesive
mix that sets into a solid block
they insert several steel support rods
fill to the top and even out the surface
then expose two hooks they'll grab to
extract the core half once the sand
hardens in about 20 minutes
[Music]
meanwhile other workers use an aluminum
pattern to make each half of the duck
casting mold
after applying a powder release agent to
prevent sticking they cover the pattern
with a sieved mixture of sand and clay
they mount a frame around the pattern to
contain the sand as they add more and
more repeatedly packing it down in all
areas with a Pneumatic ramming tool
then they remove the frame and cover the
sand with a wooden board this provides a
hard surface for the Press which now
applies the weight of about four
mid-size SUVs
then they flip the mold over and remove
the pattern which formed the mold cavity
the sand is now so firmly compacted that
it holds the shape
one half of the sand mold has channels
through which the molten metal will flow
into the cavity
workers now position several six
millimeter thick foam spacers in the
cavity and place half of the core on top
of them the spacers Elevate the core
creating a six millimeter cavity between
core and mold the other half of the core
goes on top
after placing spacers on top of that to
create a six millimeter gap on this side
as well they carefully lower the other
half of the sand mold
now they're ready to cast The Duck
the melting point of aluminum is 590
degrees Celsius however they heat it
much higher to 760 degrees so it'll flow
faster and fill the entire cavity before
beginning to solidify
they pour the metal through holes on top
it flows through the runners into the
mold cavity which is that six millimeter
Gap surrounding the duct-shaped core
about 20 minutes later the metal has
cooled and solidified
they break the mold apart on a vibrating
sieve releasing the aluminum duct and
shaking out the core sand through a hole
at the bottom of the duck
after cutting off excess aluminum that
hardened in the runners they grind down
the seam which formed in between the two
halves of the mold
next they weld on aluminum handles for
the child to grip when riding these
handles are cast in sand molds just like
the duck
[Music]
workers grind down the Weld and any
sharp edges making the entire surface
nice and smooth
next a coat of polyester powder in
bright rubber ducky yellow
then a 20-minute trip through an oven to
bake the coating making it Ultra durable
now delicately airbrushed with a
urethane enamel paint the details that
bring Mr duck to life his feet Wings
Bill and eyes
the thick coil that makes this a spring
Rider is made of a flexible type of
Steel
[Music]
they bolt a steel spacer plate to it
then hide the bolts under an aluminum
cover
after attaching a foot rest steel again
they bolt the duct to the plate
all these parts like the duck are
painted with baked on polyester coating
spring bolts to a concrete block buried
underground
ducky and friends are designed to
withstand even the harshest Winters
letting children enjoy a little spring
all year round
[Music]